well the may 2012 home price numbers
that I produced with case and SP are
showing a 2.2 percent rise in home
prices nationally in the month of May
and that is pretty good you know if that
were to keep going that would be a boom
but I'm I'm not so sure that a lot of
people are saying that this is a the
beginning of a new housing boom maybe
but I'm not so sure it it's partly
seasonal it's partly something that
happens every summer and beyond that
it's still hard to hard to see clearly
one thing that helps explain the
increase in home prices is a decline in
foreclosures foreclosure activities
usually involve a lot of homes selling
at a very low price I think that the
decline in foreclosures is is also
creating a sense of increased optimism
at the moment which is also helping to
propel prices upward but this is not the
clear to me not that clear a sign of a
of a new uptrend I think this might have
been the bottom that we just passed home
prices might be going up but the idea
that they're going up at anything like
2.2% a month is not clear in my mind it
might very well be a modest rebound in
home prices and I don't I don't see
really solid reason to get excited about
home price increases now because it
seems like they're we're still in such a
difficult economic situation and not
just the US but also Europe which is in
recession and and Asia or Asia is
weakening so the idea that this is we're
off to the races again it's just not
supported by this new evidence
a lot of people are wondering now who
are thinking of selling a house whether
they should wait and hold off for the
price increases that seem to be coming
and the buyers are wondering whether
they should hurry up and buy but i don't
i know i think in making a decision like
that the outlook is sufficiently murky
that we shouldn't try to be so
speculative and time our decisions not
now with regard to the market it can go
either way so I'm thinking that housing
is quite affordable now with very low
mortgage rates prices have come down a
lot and so anyone who is really
interested in buying a home for the long
term should do that they shouldn't be
deterred by the uncertainty in the
market which is always there if it's
important for your life by it but the
other beyond that the idea of buying a
home son speculative right now I just
have to say maybe if you know what
you're buying but it's it's going to be
risky now there's still a lot of
uncertainty it could go either way